star trek creators have proven they know
how to turn on the funny since the
beginning whether it's entire episodes
hilarious scenes or little more than a
couple of lines of dialogue here's what
we count as the funniest moments in the
history of star trek
one of the most fun conflicts to witness
on star trek deep space nine is the back
and forth between constable odo and the
scheming ferengi quark perhaps their
funniest exchange happens in season
fours the way of the warrior just before
the epic battle between the eponymous
station and a fleet of klingon ships
finding quark outside his bar odo tells
him it's time to head to the emergency
shelter but quark assures odo he intends
to defend his property quark isn't known
for being able to defend himself against
so much as a tribble much less
battle-hardened klingon warriors so odo
is understandably skeptical the
bartender produces a box that he thinks
holds a disrupter pistol when he opens
the box boldly claiming he'll be ready
for the klingons rather than a weapon
there's a note inside without skipping a
beat or asking permission odo grabs the
note and reads it it's from quark's
brother rahm informing him he gutted his
disrupter to fix their replicator it's
here that odo hits quark with a real
zinger
i will kill him
with what
deanna troy's intrusive and flirtatious
mother luaxana played by the late maegel
barrett provides a tremendous amount of
comic relief whenever she shows up in
her third appearance on star trek the
next generation her predicament forces
captain picard to deliver a speech so
ridiculously over the top that even if
you've never watched tng you've likely
seen the memes inspired by it after will
riker deanna and luaxana are kidnapped
by the ferengi daemon tag luaxana
succeeds in getting riker and her
daughter sent back to the enterprise by
promising to be togg's lover when the
enterprise contacts talk waksana
pretends she doesn't want to be rescued
telling picard that it's over between
them deanna figures out what her mother
is doing and tells picard he will have
to fight for her in a display so
melodramatic it would even make william
shatner groan picard professes his love
for luaxana threatens tog with
annihilation and recites famous lines
from shakespearean sonnets with as much
grandiose flair as he can muster
my
love is a fever
longing still for that which longer
nurses the disease
worf watches in disgust looking like
he's about to rage puke it's picard like
you've never seen him and probably
wouldn't want to see him again
in star trek the original series the
season 2 episode the trouble with
tribble starts off on a serious note the
enterprise is already on its way to deep
space station k7 but they put the pedal
to the metal when they receive an alert
that their destination is under attack
this alert proves to be a false alarm
though dangers do await at k7 a
domineering federation bureaucrat a
klingon spy and a space trader named
cyrano jones who sells members of the
enterprise crew some of the most
troublesome pets in the galaxy tribbles
the trouble with tribbles is a classic
and one of the first examples of a
whimsically goofy original series
episode that makes a point of not taking
itself too seriously from the countless
puffballs that multiply faster than a
gremlin in a tropical storm to the
ridiculous bar room brawl between the
klingons and enterprise crew to the
peddler cyrano jones willing to risk
life and limb in order to score a free
drink the trouble with tribbles is a
great time
to celebrate his upcoming marriage to
dad zia in the ds9 episode titled you
are cordially invited dwarf invites
chief o'brien and dr bashir among others
to the ritual of kalhaya thinking they
can expect the klingon version of a
bachelor party they happily accept but
rather than drinking or exotic dancers
the path to kauhai involves fasting for
four days and nights being drained of
blood hanging from a pole over intense
heat and other creative forms of torture
when wharf abruptly cancels the wedding
bashir and o'brien are thrilled to cut
their torment short
they head straight to quarks for a feast
but before they can sink their teeth in
cisco and martok arrive to let them know
the wedding's back on when quark takes
their untouched food away you can
practically hear them whining like
disappointed puppies
after several vowels from both friends
that they're going to kill wharf the
wedding finally arrives part of the
friend's duty as per klingon tradition
is to attack wharf and jazia with
blunted weapons called mastakas while
everyone else applauds the newlyweds
kiss bashir looks like obi-wan kenobi
waiting for a force field to come down
now
not yet
martok finally gives the word bashir and
o'brien rush wharf and jadzia with cries
of rage and the credits roll to sounds
of the mock battle
one of the best star trek films
featuring the original cast is 1986's
star trek iv the voyage home in order to
answer an alien probe's call which is
blindly triggering power losses and
apocalyptic storms on earth kirk and his
crew must go back in time to recover a
humpback whale a species extinct by the
23rd century while original series sent
the heroes back in time on multiple
occasions none of those stories feel as
natural or believable as in star trek iv
rather than experiencing any particular
physical threat the biggest challenge
they face is culture shock they don't
have money when they try to use a bus
they're foiled by the need for exact
change and in particular they're
confused by what spock calls quote
colorful metaphors i.e all the swearing
the best scene involves kirk and spock
trying to earn the trust of the marine
biologist dr jillian taylor kirk is
attempting and failing to seem like the
normal one compared to spock when kirk
suggests the three of them get dinner
one of the most natural adorably funny
moments in the franchise unfolds you
guys like italian
no no no yes
no yes
i love italian
due to the meddling of the mischievous
entity q one of star trek's greatest
villains captain picard his senior staff
and picard's old flame vosh find
themselves transported to sherwood
forest in season 4's cupid there's
little about cupid that won't make you
laugh picard and his senior officers are
made up as robin hood's merry men
including data who bears the famous bald
dome of friar tuck wharf is predictably
the most incensed by the situation
famously complaining to picard sir
i protest i am not a merry man
the most laugh out loud moment comes as
jordy rests and plucks at his mandolin
without comment or permission worf
calmly walks over grabs the instrument
and smashes it against a nearby tree
the prime directive prohibits members of
starfleet from interfering with the
natural progression of any society
outside the united federation of planets
serving as a comically dangerous example
of why this code exists is the original
series season 2 episode a piece of the
action 100 years before the events of
the episode sigma eosha 2 is visited by
the earthship horizon
to help teach the planet's natives the
horizon crew leaves behind a number of
books including a non-fiction book
titled chicago mobs of the 20s after the
horizon leaves the eoceans come to see
this book as a holy text and base their
entire culture on it when kirk spock and
mccoy beam down to the planet they find
a world where just about every grown
male dresses and speaks like tough guys
in mobster movies people openly carry
tommy guns up and down the street as if
there's nothing strange about it a piece
of the action gets even funnier once
kirk and spock are outfitted in their
own mobster getups and kirk attempts a
chicago gangster impersonation shatner
wouldn't fool anyone on earth and it's
tough to tell whether that's intentional
which just makes the whole thing even
funnier early in season 5 of ds9 the
series made television history with
trials and tribulations where the cast
of the show is sent back in time to the
1967 original series episode the trouble
with tribbles this episode uses every
opportunity to poke fun at the franchise
o'brien the tireless engineer is so lost
on the enterprise that when he tries to
perform routine maintenance he takes out
all the nearby lights bashir gets hit on
by a woman he's convinced is his great
grandmother and afterward he considers
the possibility that if he doesn't get
involved with her he might never be born
hands down the best moment comes when a
waitress points out a table full of
klingons everyone but wharf is confused
because of course klingons look a lot
different in the original series it's
the first time in the franchise anyone
acknowledges what appears to be a
glaring inconsistency and it comes off
perfectly
they are klingons
and it is a long story
imagine you're suddenly transported to
the 23rd century and you need to use a
computer more advanced than anything
you'd ever seen
now consider the opposite scenario and
that's what happens in star trek iv
on their quest to bring 20th century
humpback whales back to the 23rd century
scotty mccoy and sulu are tasked with
figuring out a way to construct a
makeshift aquarium aboard the bounty
while sulu secures an aircraft scotty
and mccoy find a plexiglass manufacturer
and pretend to be famous scientists with
an appointment to tour the factory at
the end of the tour scotty plans to
offer the head of the plant dr nichols
the futuristic formula for transparent
aluminum but he needs to use nickel's
computer to prove it can work
unfortunately scotty has a little
trouble computer
computer
thinking he's figured it out mccoy hands
scotty the mouse smiling widely scottie
holds the mouse to his face like a
walkie-talkie and says
hello computer
just use the keyboard
1989's star trek five the final frontier
is considered one of the worst films in
the series though it is not without its
merits while it's one of the funnier
entries in the franchise some of its
detractors would argue that the movie's
over-reliance on humor weighs it down
but one easy uncharacteristically
slapstick moment in star trek five
remains as an incredibly uproarious gag
after the force's loyal disbox fanatical
brother cybock sees control of the
enterprise kirk spock and mccoy are
imprisoned in the brig scotty soon frees
them with explosives and the liberated
trio makes a plan to sneak their way to
the emergency transmitter when the
subject of search parties comes up
scotty gives them directions he's
confident will steer them clear of cybox
people before they rush off kirk
emphatically thanks scotty and calls him
amazing turning and walking in the other
direction scotty mutters
nothing amazing about it i know this
ship like the back of my hand
if that were true though he should have
easily been able to avoid that bulkhead
it's perfectly timed and classic
if you understand the context the single
word response warf delivers to quark in
the season 4 ds9 episode of session
should make you laugh hard enough to
knock you out of any recliner couch or
captain's chair dr bashir and o'brien
are sharing a drink in quark's bar
discussing the news that o'brien's wife
keiko is pregnant with another baby it's
just then that behind bashir and o'brien
quark runs into wharf and says did you
hear keiko's gonna have another baby
to understand what happens next you need
to know that five years earlier in the
season five tng episode disaster much of
the enterprise is rendered inoperable
and most of the crew is stranded in
different parts of the ship this of
course is when keiko o'brien pregnant
with her first baby goes into labor
while stuck in 10 forward as the most
qualified crew member but still with
precious little medical knowledge worf
is the one who's forced to assist with
keiko's pregnancy so this is why five
years later in a session when quark
delivers the news wharf's immediate
reaction is to respond with a panicked
now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]